[Music]
all right let's go to grace in duluth
what's up grace how are we doing
holy cow i'm talking to john baloney i
just did the same thing holy cow i'm
talking to grace this is amazing
what's up how are you i'm good i'm good
how about you
i am a huge fan and it's an honor to
talk to you well thank you and i'm a
huge fan of yours also
a huge boat because i haven't been
exercising and huge
because just in size and scope so so
what's up how can i help you cool
um
so i have an eight-year-old daughter who
is
just everything that is wonderful in the
world full of sass energy heart all of
it
um
but she's struggling and
i don't know how much of it is because
she has started going through puberty
and how much of it is due to abuse that
she's witnessed at home
so tell me about the abuse she's
witnessed
um
her dad had undiagnosed bipolar and he
was mentally emotionally
abusive to her he was mentally
emotionally physically
financially sexually abusive to me
she was six when she watched him like
inappropriately grope me and i would try
and push him away and say not from her
whatever
um she's asked me several times why
daddy touched your boobies when you
didn't want him to
um what was your answer
i said daddy's not
he was sick daddy we've talked about his
bipolar compared it to a teeter-totter
that everybody has emotions that go up
and down
daddy's teeter-totter is just really
really big is dad still living at home
um no i
we're divorced um i kicked him out i
realized
when i finally realized that he had
actually been raping me
um
and then just knowing the how the abuse
was affecting her like she tackled a kid
at school that was picking on her
friends she made another kid bleed
because they were restraining her like
she was constantly tearful constantly
you know saying mommy can you tell daddy
to be nice to me because she would only
the only way he would speak to her would
be yelling
um so let me stop here let me stop you
yeah
i am
proud of you
for
doing a really hard thing
and there's a level of bravery and
strength that um
most people never understand what you've
experienced and
the choice to enter into being a single
mom
and
i'm proud of you for doing that
for you for her for your legacy okay
i'm proud of you that's hard
you do the right thing
okay and by the way
mental health diagnostics are a context
not an excuse
okay right
right so i don't care what diagnosis he
has
nobody gets to put his hands on you
nobody gets to sexually assault or rape
you nobody gets to hurt you or your
children right
okay i'm proud of you it's hard
i also know living with somebody with
bipolar makes you feel crazy is that
right
i still feel crazy i know you do and so
now we're going to enter into a season
of you reclaiming
your own two feet right
yeah okay
i'm proud of you it's hard hard hard
hard and you're a strong brave human
being do you have people in your life
that you can lean on
i have
i do yeah okay
you cannot go forward alone and you know
that but make sure you got people you
can call or text at all hours of the
night okay so your question's about your
little one all right so tell me about
what she's experiencing because she's
got some school stuff that
i mean some very sh she's
um
she's
of justice experienced
you go yeah she has a very strong sense
of justice so if someone is wronging
someone she cares about or wronging her
she will fly off the handle she does not
um
she doesn't handle male discipline well
even if it's hey we've asked you to
brush your teeth three times you know
you need to do it now
um she doesn't handle any kind of male
sternness well it scares her yes um
so think of
from this point forward
think of
men telling her what to do in her life
as um
as a horror movie character with a
hatchet
right okay there's no there's no
processing it there's no making the next
right good choice it is a little child's
body that goes that is
pretty sure it's gonna die and it
responds accordingly okay and so that
healing looks like not being a little
more less sassy or a little more like
compliant it is i've gotta heal a brain
that sees a man and sets off an alarm
right
she's been in counseling um
for over a year and a half she's also in
so she does like counseling with a
therapist but she also does skills
counseling
that teaches her how to
gives her tools on how to deal with her
anxiety look at context of situations
yelling at me yes because i wasn't
listening or were they yelling at me
because i mean so we've been doing all
of that but
i just like she
even i have to and i'm okay with it i
understand it but even i have to ask
permission to give her hugs and kisses
yes and her dad's dad unfortunately who
also has bipolar
um will will get on her for not giving
him a hug no no no no no no give me a
hug yeah no no way and
that that ends today
that is today okay so here's here's what
here's what she's learning
she had a um
okay a couple things
when kids witness domestic violence and
by the way um i checked in with my
friend who's an expert in this before um
yeah uh i called her she's a savant and
she goes into these situations regularly
and um
so
i actually didn't know this as much as
i've worked with trauma and with little
ones that i didn't know this particular
thing that kids when they witness
the abuse like you experienced
their little bodies take it on as though
it happened to them right and so i want
you to you a counselor may have told you
that i didn't know it was that visceral
i didn't know i knew a kid who
experienced their parents i didn't
realize that it experienced in the way
that she was explaining it to me so
right they can it can the range of
effects for a kid that sees this but
including they will tell the story as
though it happened to them okay
so all she's trying to figure out is
body autonomy and she doesn't have a
picture of that because the most
powerful beautiful wonderful strong
woman she's ever met had her body
taken over by somebody else
right and so i
think the greatest gift you can give her
is teaching her body boundaries meaning
you modeling for her can i hug you can i
high-five you and my daughter has never
witnessed sexual abuse and i do this
with her
have you heard me tell that story here
tons of times yeah um it's a big deal
that i i reach in because i like her
hugs make me feel better right they just
do and she knows that so she weaponizes
them because she's sick
and
i ask can i give you a hug and she'll
say no thank you
and then i will say cool and i'll move
on with my day okay so yeah no man no
father-in-law that's when you get
between him and your daughter
and you say he does she does not have to
hug you in fact she will not hug you
anymore
because you don't have a right to her
body
okay i feel good about that i feel
strong about that
yeah
the mama bearing me just like
yes
yes and if he says
i have
then you don't have access to my child
anymore bye
right bye you just don't like i don't i
don't need you in my life in fact you're
more of a burden to my family than not
right
um so
do you have like a man i feel like i'm
interrupting you and just answering
because i have a visceral response to
this too and i know you live it so
um
tell me how i can help is there a
specific situation i can help you with
um
so
oh i so intended on
making this completely 100 percent about
her and i feel selfish turning it back
on me a little bit hey listen um listen
so anything to do with your kids
well-being starts with mom starts with
dad i know okay so don't feel a second
of guilt you getting well is a gr a
great gift you can give your daughter
okay
so just a tiny bit more just a tiny bit
more back story um i've been in therapy
on and off for 20 years third depression
anxiety eating disorders ptsd i was
abused when i was eight assaulted at 19
raped at 21 so i have a what you would
call a rich backstory
a rich history i have hey i wouldn't
college be a psychology i went to sing i
went to college for psychology
i would not call this a rich backstory i
would call this a devastating
set of like a devastating traumatic
story right but i also understand you've
got to smile to walk through days
sometimes so okay
so i've been in therapy now for the last
two and a half years i started before my
marriage is even over thinking that i
was the problem right
how do i help her continue to process
through
all this abuse
when is triggering for me
every single day yeah
it may be a moment where
um you need to go do an intensive
or you both go do an intensive
yeah because you need to pause if you
can afford it
um you need to pause
because
if you were the abuse started in your
life when you were eight then your body
looks at her and remembers that and
starts sounding the alarms right
it's a very common common response there
um
and her tension
she feeds off your tension
and i know that puts a ton of
responsibility on you
but she feeds off that and then tries to
solve it and right now she's solving it
with control and with justice and with
violence
and with right sass and humor too right
which is probably how you probably solve
a lot of the problems in similar ways
you're funny you're silly you're all
that and you can
mama bear can come out too right
so
i think
whether it's an intensive or
you can model what getting well looks
like and if that means you have to find
somebody that you highly highly trust
that's not related to this knuckleheaded
family
um and go for 30 days and get well at an
intensive or do a couple of weekends in
a row
modeling for her
like daddy hurt mommy
and when i was a little girl other
people hurt mommy too and mommy's gonna
go get well because mommy's worth being
loved and mommy's worth being safe
and mommy's gonna learn some things that
can help you be safe too
yeah see what i'm saying and here's
here's where kids pick things up so
um
somebody let's say i'm just gonna make
somebody up okay so
um let's say a stranger wearing
i don't know
with a mustache was one of the people
who abused you as a kid
like your dad's friend who had a
mustache and you happen to find yourself
at a target with your daughter and some
dude with a mustache reminds your body
your daughter will pick up on you
almost imperceptibly
squeezing her hand a little bit tighter
right her body knows we're not we're not
okay everybody tense up and we get
smaller but disappear right and we're
gonna get to this next aisle
so that's the level here
and when i say um
doing the hard work an intensive getting
well here's what we're looking for can i
remember what happened without my body
taking off on me that's what we're
looking to do
and when i say taking off on me without
that trauma response happening okay
okay
you've been in counseling a long time
what are you getting from counseling
um
at first it was
am i the problem in my marriage and then
it was okay i'm gonna
pull the plug on my marriage and now i'm
gonna process through the divorce
um and all the abuse and everything and
we're
it's been almost a year now that we've
been divorced so now i feel like
i'm ready to start going into like emdr
or some kind of intensive um i was there
at one point and then covet happened and
i couldn't do it
and then covet just put a magnifying
glass on his bipolar and that's when all
the abuse started and i'm locked in a
house with this guy if you're a kid if
you were my sister i would tell you to
start with the mdr
okay that's a great place to start
and um
and it may be that you end up on
medication for a season great it may be
that you end up at a 30-day inpatient
hanging out with people just doing
intensive groups all day great
wherever your healing journey takes you
let this thing stop with you
yeah you know what i mean
yeah
let's stop with you and you're gonna get
beat up on it you're gonna have scars
and you're worth the journey and you're
worth the trip
right
yeah
one thing i want to tell you okay and i
want you to hang on the line i'm gonna
send you a copy of my of my book okay
uh my new one i already have it oh you
gotta read it okay that's amazing you
did so good all right well i was gonna
tell you here's what happens next and
it's in there but i'm gonna tell you
this okay
sexual abuse takes people's autonomy
from them
somebody else takes their body from them
they take their worth from them and then
somehow the shame mechanism flips it
around as though it was your fault
yeah
living inside a relationship with an
abusive person does the same thing
sometimes living with untreated bipolar
does the same thing
and so here's what i want you to be
sometimes and it's going to sound awful
i don't want to equate the two but it
can be very similar
20 years in counseling
where you go every week or every other
week and just talk about your problem
over time it slowly lets the air out of
your power
your strength
when somebody sexually abuses you they
take your power from you they take your
strength when you are in the house
locked up with a tiger who has bipolar
who refuses to do the work that it takes
to get well
it takes your power from you and so
moving forward i don't want you to go to
counseling anymore just to talk about
stuff
i want you to go to counseling
to form a connection
so that you can begin to heal and get
your power back
okay yeah so the journey here is
reclaiming your strength
and part of reclaiming strength is
learning trust it's learning how to
control your breathing it's learning how
to say no
when some man says
you have to give me a hug to your
daughter you get between them and smile
real big and say you leave my house with
us and your heart rate never even gets
up it doesn't even spike on you that's
how in control you are right listen
here's the other side of it
you're so strong you can just lay down
and go to sleep at night no meds no
netflix no instagram you just go to
sleep right and you sleep all night
and somebody texts you and you don't
even feel like looking you see what i'm
saying like this is about getting
grace's power back
okay yeah
and what you're gonna find real quick
real quick
you are so much stronger than you think
holy smokes dude you are so much
stronger than you think and you've got
so much more power than you think
and it's it's less about i gotta like
there is some weightlifting you gotta do
and there's some new skills you gotta
learn but this is more about somebody
going into a barn and there's a like a
tarp over something and they rip that
tarp back
and there's a ferrari under there that
is brand stinking new
and that's you
and so what we're gonna do over the next
few months is we're gonna you're gonna
tell your therapist
i'm ready to start healing we spent a
year building relationship and rapport
great we are about healing now and i'm
gonna do whatever it takes
and
i'm gonna get control of my body i'm
gonna get my strength and my power back
and if the therapist is worth their salt
they're gonna say all right and they're
gonna stand up and rip that tarp off and
show you a mirror
that you're a ferrari ready to rock and
roll so proud of you you can do it you
can do it you can do it and by the way
your daughter needs that level of
strength too okay your daughter needs
that level of strength too so continue
to get her the help and care that she
needs
and man teach her how important
her words are when it comes to who's in
control of her body man she's lucky to
have you
let's go get well